hey guys i'm off the grid for august but
brian stelter is still an unlikable
potato in their words oliver you know we
got short shrift this week the house
passing that historic climate bill the
inflation reduction act one of the
components of the bill is a lot more
funding for the irs to hire tens of
thousands of more irs agents in order to
try to make sure people are paying how
much they're supposed to pay what was
that called on the right it was called a
terrifying overreach by the government
the reason i'm bringing it up is
let's just
call it what it is mag of media's hatred
of government is reaching a new high
when you have a combination of these fbi
stories and the irs getting a lot more
funding this is a new peak in terms of
that anti-government sentiment so it's
no wonder that there's concern with
inside government about security and
about threats yeah and i mean the rights
always advocated for small governments
but in this case it's i think the
particularly talking about the fbi it's
not necessarily a pro-small government
approach or taking they just want to
defund the whole thing and abolish it
because it's uh probing a political
figure that they happen to support and i
think what you have to point out
repeatedly and i know we have is that
when the fbi was investigating hillary
clinton you know they were very
supportive of the fbi and of that
investigation that was happening right
before the 2016 election uh trump hasn't
even declared yet and they're basically
uh you know out there assaulting the fbi
and attack or you know with rewards but